あれたさああああ
どこかにいい pu t 4スポーツクロスてもこんにちははじめ社長です
言うの忘れたんですけれども実は iphone に変えました
小月に言いましょう
変えないほうが良かったですなんか iphone 目ちょっと貼るんだけどな
ツイッターのをやっててもたまになんかこの考え中マークになってものすごいちょっと
まあミスったらまぁ全然疲れシーンですよつかん屋さん一緒ばかりやすくていいんです
けどまぁちょっとなんかギャラクシーのほうが良かったすごく
今日はねまあ僕のよろご飯を食べようというところです
これはでも東濃ですとと失望つ注意とどの
あれなに今大和にっていうのトド肉塩50%だから半分塔ですね
なぜ下地窓でよりシーズやろうみたいな話してたんですけどもうちょっと8時間がなく
て
今に行っちゃいましたでもなんか完全なから賞味期限のもちろん長いんですよなんだよ
ちょっととドって書いてある見えるかなを読めないよねちゃんととドって書いてある
からねこんな感じらしいですね
なんか晒しの時はちょっとアザラシて可愛いイメージがあったからちょっと食べ
づらかったんですけどもなんかとドア
なんかごはんタコ
ん
何の音なんか種採り暮らししてると怖いするものとなってきてご飯を炊いている間に
上げてみましょい
ああ怖いなぁながガチャが映ってるん
ねえ割と根や日ため味レイズ今えげつないですね
意外と美味しそうなんですよねあなぜとぞ説明会であると度は海のジャンルと呼ばれ
うわぁ魚の網を破り魚を大量に食べる表紙の大敵です
ハーイ貼るやつじゃんその時は大その肉は北海道ならではの珍味です
美味しさを損なわないようになんか色々生姜とか味噌はずっと負けしました
はぁ通ってめっちゃいえつじゃん表紙の魚をたくさんで住んでるのか
そんな悪いやつなのかこれ食われても仕方ない夏井
いる超夜ご飯はとどの味噌煮とスロご飯でそれがほぼニート大学生の生活だよみんな
覚えときはかける路線でいくん
うまそうなんだよね割とほとんど肉食ったことある人いますか
聞いたことがないしこんなとか悪い奴とも思わなかったもうちょっと嫌いになっちゃっ
たよ
こんな感じのお肉ですお肉自体はなんかよくわかんない取れず
ちょっとメテみますいただきますとっ
うん甘いほど甘い味付けの星がふだらく力でた馬術くださいか知らないですけど多分
新しいよりおいしかったですねってなんでとっても柔らかいんですよ
まあ梅はと二度おいしい
なんかずっと前から同じようだと言ってる気がするんですけどありと僕忙しいんですよ
その時間に追われているバーバーってわけじゃないんですけれどもだね素晴らしい探す
人ばっかりだと思うけどサーフ心
頑張るからさ大変だよなかああ
俺もちょっと今ちょっとよくわかんで上演だけどみんながんばろうやー
あいやなことがあってもな嬉しいことはその先にあるなら
俺頑張るようにハサミのっていうことでねあ俺も頑張るからされたとりあえずでどうぞ
を通して何かみんなに元気与えればいいなと思ってるんだよ
頑張ろうじゃ
me